against someone I can't get up for
leverage I don't have leverage so I'll
use my shoulder
and then I'll have made it today all I
gotta do is get rid of this race name
here
boom
okay
hit down to the groin you get that
little Flinch in him and you're gonna do
uh a Coq projection to the rear so my
hit hold and coming this way okay it is
over here okay and now you have the wall
pin on here okay
okay so if he we're here right and pop
and I I have my projections but remember
that's going to the ground so same thing
here
no I'm here okay coming in just for my
finger wherever I touch it doesn't
matter where I come don't look for
something wherever I touch and that's
there's the energy a little right in
there and that's what I project
okay then I come around and then the
same thing here
um
so he's trying to push me we do these
stabilizing drills same thing here uh he
can't he can't push me he's not going to
push me over he's not going to push me
ever okay
same thing here
when I'm here
I mean he tries to push off the wall
it's not here
it's on the ground he pushes Off the
Wall we're not going anywhere okay and
that's where I deliver that strike using
the wall so if I'm able to I'm going to
hit him with the wall again his head
comes off the wall oh I dropped his head
back onto the wall you know and or hit
the back of his leg so his kneecap hits
the wall okay that's gonna be my thing
I'm gonna I'm gonna use the wall to help
my uh ballistics of my strike if you get
enough Buckle going
then you can drop drown all that knee
that way and hit it with your knee so he
up I had enough buckles enough angle of
incidence here that as opposed to
kicking here
and kicking again wish you can I'm just
still pinning and I'll drop my whole
body into that knee and check his height
with that knee strike and then he
doesn't give back to your ballistics
okay
so play with that but I'd like to see
the ground more you want some other
environmental concerns right so I'm here
boom doing my technique top come in look
at all that hair okay so all that hair
can work uh very much for me do you see
boom and crack that thing in there so a
lot of people have lots of hair
[Music]
I thought I'd be doing this on a woman
but
some dudes have hair
you have the hair and you crack that uh
ponytail or man bun into the wall in in
your same inward spiral I'll be Demi
nugget ah you crack that thing there
okay so if they have hair look for the
hair uh sometimes they have hoodies and
stuff you can do it too with hoodies all
that kind of stuff all right
he's trying to get me in that last
position okay we're not there so his
intention is wrong here like
if you stay here
that's when you get this uh angle
cancellation on your body
so as as he's coming in right we could
maybe like he got his hands on there so
instead of uh
uh in other words I don't have I don't
have time he goes like this doesn't have
time to do something this line is like
right here so I mean you got my head and
if I leave my feet there he's going to
get the angle cancellation so as he goes
I lock my body and my whole body moves
back he moves my body back my Center is
locked and he moves my body back
boom that's where I get out okay boom
check this height and we'll come down to
the groin this way and the wall is there
boom and we'll shallow into the wall
again
so just like it's the same thing as as
he's pushing my Center is not
disengaged between my torso and my legs
it's engaged so when he hits the top of
my body it doesn't do that to me
he pushes my whole body
down to the groin boom and now you have
his head walk here and poke you into the
wall
foreign
[Music]